well sadly our oceans that suffering in
many ways I would put plastics high up
there you know there are areas in in the
oceans that are as big as bigger than
Great Britain just thick thick horrible
classic that is it has been dropped in
over many many years some people might
say well is it just kind of a ground
version of a Keep Britain Tidy campaign
it's cosmetic it's making things look
nicer get the plastic out of the ocean
and it won't be spoil it it has a huge
effect doesn't it on ocean life and
indeed then through the food chain the
plastic in the oceans gets eaten and it
breaks down it gets eaten by fish and
and it does pollute pollute our own
bodies altima t so and you know it'll
get wrapped around turtles it'll kill
turtles and there you know they'll eat
it it'll choke on it and they'll get
caught up in it so you know so it's most
definitely a major a major global
problem that we need to come up with
imaginative ways of addressing and you
know does humans should be bright enough
to build to sort it well you've been
thinking about that for quite a long
time haven't you with your ocean elders
groups and other campaigns you're
involved in so give us some of your
suggestions on how this huge problem can
be tackled well I think I mean all of us
are guilty and you know I suddenly find
myself doing interview like this and
finding I've got a you know a plastic
bottle in my hand or you know it's
fitting I bet you it's right behind me
as I'm talking so we've all got to just
try to avoid that we've got to try to
make sure that if we do have a plastic
bottle it's the kind of bottle that we
can refill you know every day of the
year
and preferably every day of you know
over the next five or ten years and and
so it's it's not throw a wearable and
one way of encouraging that is to do
what I think the organization is is
campaigning for and and that is to
actually get governments to tell
retailers and to give money back if
people bring bring the bottles back and
and in countries like Germany where
they've done that something like 98% of
the bottles are returned well you and I
remember when that applied I guessed it
to glass bottles remember in bottles of
Pop you used to take them back and get
you six months back yeah and you you
it's not just the people who use the
bottles to take them back kids all over
the country they're going to want to
make a bit of money so if somebody is
foolish enough to lis leave a plastic
bottle lying around
you know kids will make some extra money
on the side from it so so I think it's a
it's a fantastic idea and one that
should be encouraged we're talking about
corporate responsibility and the ability
of big employers to just change habits
really I suppose much becomes a habit
then becomes more natural to use a
reusable bottle but there are big
corporations of course that make an
awful lot of money out of putting
liquids into plastic bottles and selling
many many of them how can you change
that high I'm afraid that you know the
people who make a lot of money out of
things that are not doing the
environment any good have to have to
change their approach so the coal
industry I mean it's it's on its knees I
mean Trump I'm sure will do his best to
save it but it shouldn't be saved it
should it should die graceful death and
people should you know should move from
coal to clean energies and you know
where you have millions and millions of
bits of plastic bottles being produced
and sold all over the world if people
can come up with alternatives then the
people who are making those plastic
bottles are going to have to ideally
come up with those alternatives
themselves and and if they're going to
stay in business
clearly governments can have a massive
influence he and we talked about some of
the initiatives in other countries do
you think given what President Trump has
said on the campaign trail about his
attitude overall towards the environment
towards climate change that this is
certainly not going to be something on
his list of priorities I find it
astonishing what what he's had to say
about the environment and about rolling
back I think the positive moves that
President Obama and and and even
President Bush and other people have
done
before and obviously it's extremely
worrying and therefore I think business
leaders well why they're going to have
to step in and work with the public and
in in you know doing what we believe to
be right and I mean for instance I mean
we you know our Ocean elders has worked
with successive prime ministers and
presidents around the world to try to
encourage massive marine reserves to be
created in different parts of the world
and make it their legacy of their
positive legacy and David Cameron
created two of the biggest marine
reserves in the world before he left
office President Obama created the
biggest marine reserve in the world
before he left office and these marine
reserves are really important because it
means that you know people people cannot
you know the big fishing boats that that
do so much damage cannot fish in in
these marine reserves and it gives a
chance of a fish to rejuvenate and with
the ocean elders would you hope to get
some kind of time with members of the
Trump administration to push this
forward yes of course I mean we we will
you know we've lobbied successful
governments over the last you know I
mean every every new government that
comes into power we sit down and we try
to persuade them of the merits of our
case and the scientific merits of our
case and would certainly be trying to do
the same with the Trump administration
as we've done with you know much more
easily as opposed with other
administrations where you wouldn't be
knocking on an open door so actually
thank you very much indeed
pleasure thank you